[Music]
this week on
forward I felt more and more as I did
work around homelessness that it was
this highly
individualized disaster this non-shared
trauma really like everyone just went
through an earthquake or a flood or a
fire but no one knows that the other
person just went through the same thing
we would never look at each other as
like housed people as a primary identity
and yet we've defined an entire group of
people by their lack of one physical
need which is the homeless given the
precarity of you know 40% of people not
knowing where they get $400 for an
unexpected emergency it's actually
surprising that we don't have more
people experiencing homelessness in this
country like what's keeping half the
country from experiencing
[Music]
homelessness hey everyone this week on
the podcast I interview an incredible
guy named Kevin Adler who started
Miracle messages and he wrote a new book
called when we walk by it's about
homelessness he spent the last 10 years
or so reconnecting 800 homeless people
to their loved ones and families uh it's
uplifting uh and
invigorating what else is going on this
week there's a guy named Dean Phillips
who's running for president that I am
having a lot of fun with uh because most
of you know I don't think Joe Biden is
the right choice to to run in 24 I think
he'd lose to Trump uh and the Democratic
party really should build some better
candidates if you want to see what I've
been thinking about Dean Phillips go to
andrewyang.com
blog uh or just actually just go to
Andrew yang.com because they they're
that that's where it is also this week
it looks like the SAG aftera strike is
over thank goodness and Studio's lost uh
when that happens you think wow couldn't
you have just cut this deal weeks or
months ago um but I'm pumped on multiple
levels of a lot of friends who are
striking um also as a consumer it'd be
nice to have some good stuff to watch as
opposed to the crap we're dealing with
right now I'm kidding there's actually
some good stuff going on right now um in
in content world uh but could always use
some more and people need to be able to
do their jobs uh and tell stories uh I
thought the midterms were a good sign in
in many respects um I think the read
though is that this means that Joe Biden
is the right choice in 2024 I think
there's a very big difference between
voting for let's say um women's
Reproductive Rights uh or a state rep in
Virginia or even a young governor in
Kentucky than voting for Joe Biden I
think Joe Biden has singular qualities
that voters ascribe to him not all of
them positive shall we say so uh excited
for you to hear this this conversation
with Kevin Adler and if you want to see
some of the things that I am thinking
about go to andrewyang.com because I do
write that stuff down subscribe to the
newsletter if you don't already CU I
send that out at least once a week and
hopefully we will have a real choice in
24 Dean Phillips team Dean check him out
we're going to have him on the podcast
before you know it too so tune in for
that hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops probably
on Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast the founder and CEO of Miracle
messages and the author of the brand new
book when we walk by forgotten Humanity
broken systems and the role we can each
play in ending homelessness in America
Kevin Adler welcome Kevin hey Andrew
thanks for having me it's good to see
you yeah it's good to see you too and
congratulations on your work first and
foremost uh and this book which is
awesome and I think timely uh I I guess
it could have been written at any point
in the last number of years it still
would have been timely know it's like oh
homeless people I mean you know
obviously it's uh um been with us but I
I will say it seems more pressing now
and you open your book with I think a
very very relatable anecdote of you
being in the Bay Area and then walking
by homeless people and then feeling sort
of uncomfortable and then saying oh like
what can I do and then your your
exertion was to smile was to make eye
contact was to like give them a thumbs
up just to acknowledge their Humanity
but it wasn't like you started being uh
um like an activist and philanthropist
in this direction you started out like
most of us yeah it it it felt pretty
basic in fact I I mean I didn't set out
to be an activist or philanthropist or
anything else I I just set out to try to
be a better person and you know having
an uncle who was homeless for 30
years i' never thought of his as Mark as
a homeless man but when he passed away I
realized that you know the love and
compassion and empathy I had for Mark
when he wasn't at our you know Christmas
and Thanksgiving dinner table did not
extend to the people I walk by every day
on the Streets of San Francisco so it
was as much a path to to build my own
capacity to see people on the streets
not as you know problems to be solved
but as people to be loved yeah so your
uncle passes away which uh hurts um you
have a something of an epiphany while
visiting his grave site with your dad um
and then you wound up actually starting
an organization that
reconnects homeless people with loved
ones uh which is now resulted in 800
plus uh people reconnecting with loved
ones and in many cases getting off the
street so how did that come to pass I
mean that's a lot uh like what happened
after you visited your uncle's grave
site um and this is at this point maybe
10 years ago yeah it's about 10 years
ago yeah I I you know I got I left the
grave site with my dad had a really
heartfelt conversation and um realized
that the intention of kind of having
this grave site for my uncle was was
really that uh we'd have a place to
commemorate Mark's life and and have a
permanent resting place for this person
who never had that in this life and um
you know I got
got home and started scrolling through
social media and realized that you know
I was learning more about my random
acquaintances on Facebook and you know
Instagram than I was at my own uncle's
grave so I just started thinking how can
we use the storytelling tools that we
have access to to help people like my
uncle Mark um you know I'm a person of
faith and uh was in church a few weeks
later pastor had this prompt who is
Jesus you had to answer that with some
kind of art form or creative expression
I'm not an artist I'm not a musician
Jesus doesn't need me to sing a song but
I was like well I've always loved using
simple tools to help share our common
humanity and kind of unveil what I feel
is ever present and I got this question
on my heart that was uh really struck me
was you know how would how would Jesus
use a
smartphone and maybe Jesus wouldn't use
a smartphone I'm kidding but if he were
to use it if he were to use it if he
were to use it um probably fewer cat
videos and uh selfies right so you
started this organization um what like
what what came first the first uh
beneficiary or homeless neighbor that
you helped or the organization itself
yeah I mean the first point was um I
spent a year just listening spent a year
with 24 individuals experiencing
homelessness who volunteered to wear
GoPro cameras around their chests wow
and narrate their experience of what
life is like on the streets and the
premise was hey I just walked by you
you're still here what's it like to be
you uh and I watched dozens of hours of
pretty heartbreaking footage and uh you
know the two things that struck me
Andrew was uh first every time you'd see
a kid walk by the kid would tug on their
mom or dad's sleeve they Point they'd
look they'd ask questions and half the
time the parent would would scold them
and say no that's dangerous don't do
that and you know I'd always think gosh
those kids probably knew something or
know something that we've forgotten as
adults um but the second piece that's
really appropo to Miracle messages
founding story was in one of the clips I
heard someone say you know I never
realized I was homeless when I lost my
housing only when I lost my family and
friends yeah you you you uh open the
book with this uh idea of relational
poverty um and and you're suggesting
that we're relationship poor and that
that kind of goes hand hand in hand with
being homeless yeah I think it's so um
it's it's such an extreme version of low
Social Capital to use the sociological
term but such a level of relational
isolation Brokenness disconnectedness
that it's almost
inconceivable uh unless you get that up
close and personal to it um you know I
um I read your book recently the war on
normal people and one of the things that
you really talk about at length is how
many people in the United States right
now are one paycheck away from not being
able to pay rent um and given the
precarity of you know 40% of people not
knowing where they get $400 for an
unexpected
emergency uh it's actually surprising
that we don't have more people
experiencing homelessness in this
country like what's keeping half the
country from experiencing homelessness
and what we're finding is Family Friends
Community Church synagogue mosque like
Community relationships and so if you
don't have that or you've lost that or
it was never quite supportive enough or
it was just so resource depressed to
begin with um it can be very difficult
to get off the streets and stay off the
streets if you're if you're in that
situation yeah you refer to this group
as the Proto homeless or maybe someone
else did which I thought was interesting
it's like the could potentially be
homeless uh if if something breaks the
wrong way um so let's try and Define
the scope of this how many people are
homeless in America at any moment in
time yeah at any given night it's just
under well depends on the estimates but
around 600,000 people experience
homelessness any given night um but over
the course of a year um people who may
come in and out of homelessness maybe
self-resolve or you know are unseen are
doubled up tripled up so maybe not what
we think of by the HUD definition as
experienc in homelessness uh you know
it's probably closer to about 10 times
that and and so in the book we estimate
about 6 million people experience
homelessness each year well it's a lot
so in a country of 330 million let's
call it something like 2% 2% MH yeah one
out of 50 might experience homelessness
in a given year one interesting thing in
your book is you actually list a bunch
of celebrities who are homeless at One
Moment In Time some of them I knew I was
like oh yeah I knew juel was homeless
but but like some of the others I was
like really like I that I didn't know
who surprised you David Letterman
surprised me David Letterman yeah Chris
Pratt I guess there was and then I
thought oh wait there was some episode
about him living in a van or
something which uh and and I feel like
vehicles are where a lot of folks take
shelter if you live in a vehicle um like
let's say your car your Toyota Camry um
are you technically homeless yes yes you
are absolutely yeah and I I I think even
within the Celebrity Circle if we widen
that to folks who are you know
Successful by whatever measures of you
know monetary Fame power a lot more
people are have experienced homelessness
than we'll will share that they have
experienced homelessness you know I I
get I bet we don't know about some of it
um it's totally true um so you start
Miracle
messages about 10 years ago and and it
starts with this footage hours and hours
of ver footage from people who are
struggling with homelessness what did
you do next yeah so I it started out uh
just to give the the quick founding
story I basically took a walk down
Market Street went up to everyone I saw
who was visibly homeless and asked do
you have any family or friends you'd
like to reconnect to met a man named
Jeffrey he said he hadn't seen his
family in 22 years sat down recorded a
short video from him to his niece and
nephew and his sister and his dad went
home that night did a search online
found a Facebook group connected to his
hometown and uh you know posted the
video there with a short note nice
work you know just the entrepreneur and
me right just get things done right and
within one hour uh the video was shared
hundreds of times made the local news
that night a classmates started
commenting saying hey I went to high
school with Jeffrey I work in
construction does he need a job you know
I work at the congressman's office does
he need Healthcare in a week the town
raised over 5,000
to try to bring him home and in the
first 20 minutes of the post his sister
got tagged and uh we got on the phone
the next day and she told me that
Jeffrey had been a missing person for 12
years no so that was that was the
starting point yeah you thought wow we
did a lot of good there we probably
saved this person's life uh it's very
heartwarming that the town rallied in
that way and so then you thought wow
like maybe there's another person like
Jeffrey you know Jeff's not the only one
and this shouldn't be happening right
you want to make a impact in the world
you have to figure out how to make the
impact in one person's life first and so
I didn't I still didn't know what I
didn't know uh I felt like a total fraud
trying to do this work because for me it
wasn't homelessness that I cared about
per se I cared about homelessness but it
wasn't my driving issue but it was just
my belief in the intrinsic value of each
person interconnectedness of us all and
you know any objective an is of
homelessness living in San Francisco
like circa 2014 2015 or Circa
2023 um people experiencing homelessness
are not seen as you know Precious part
of our community and valuable or you
know connected so I I just started
talking to people having conversations
and initially set a goal of reuniting 10
people uh hit the goal and then just
went to 100 hit that goal and then I set
a goal of a million have not hit that
goal yeah I haven't hit that goal yet
that but there's there's a lot of need
there's a lot of need so we're we're
over 800 now reunions as our first
program
so this podcast is sponsored by Helix
sleep it's a pretty short list of things
you can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive
Helix is offering 20% off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now so you have over 800 reunions um I
imagine some of these messages have gone
unanswered how many uh messes is do you
think you've put out yeah for every you
know by the Numbers what we we kind of
estimate so for every hundred messages
that we record well first for every 300
400 people that we talk to maybe 100
will want to record a message um and
it's it's not just a video message
there's audio text online form written
form and then we have a hotline uh which
I actually don't even know my wife's
phone number by heart but I know this
phone number it's a800 miss you uh so
trying to be very accessible to our
neighbors yeah so we got yeah and that's
a whole story how to get how to get a 1
1800 phone number in Modern Age they
they're it's a very complicated telepan
companies that own them but anyway so we
have 1800 miss you so for every 300 400
people that we offer a service to maybe
about a 100 will say yes I'd like to
record a message and then of those 100
50 will be able to find the loved ones
and then half of those so 25 will be
able to help facilitate a reunion uh so
you know it's it's about a quarter of
the people who record a message will end
up reuniting but when we do find the
family um and that's a big you know when
it's not all the time uh eight eight
eight times out of 10 they're excited to
reconnect and and it's a positive
outcome that's great again restore your
faith in human nature so you've been
building this very wholesome lovely
human organization over this last number
of years uh and you expanded to include
basic income over the last couple of
years for folks uh in tough
circumstances yeah we we basically we
were doing the reunion services and we
heard feedback from the people we were
serving consistently saying hey I buy
this whole relational poverty thing I'm
relationally impoverished but um my
family is part of the problem not part
of the solution what are you going to do
for me you know and and how are you
going to help me and so the starting
point for the basic income actually
began with us creating a phone buddy
program uh where we invite volunteers
initially it was in the Bay Area now
it's around the world you know folks
Chile Kenya US Canada throughout Europe
who have committed 30 minutes a week to
have a onetoone phone call or text
message exchange with an unhoused
neighbor in the US uh Big Brothers Big
Sisters for unhoused neighbors and it
was through those relationships and the
feedback we heard as people built trust
built the sense of connectedness getting
to know someone very unlike um
themselves yeah yeah I'm with these
people too it's like if you put me on
the phone with a homeless person I'd be
like yo man I'm just gonna send you 200
bucks it's like like like my pep talk
might help you somewhat but let's just
skip that and like do you have any venmo
or cash app or something I can use um
actually let me let me hit that for just
a a brief moment What proportion of uh
folks in homelessness actually have a
phone or a means of being connected that
way or a means of receiving money if I
were just to be like yo I'm just going
to send you because they probably can't
do do they have uh those tools yeah it's
a great question uh you know I mean
within the shelter population of people
who have some kind of form of shelter
it's a much higher percentage I'd say
the majority do I mean if you think if
God forbid one of us were to experience
homelessness what's the last thing
you're giving up or the first thing
you're wanting to get back back in your
hands right it's some kind of phone and
there are pro there are programs like
Obama phones and you know Lifeline
Wireless where you can by having some
kind of federal benefit be eligible for
a free phone free data plan uh
unsheltered uh homelessness you know not
only if you you may not you may have a
phone but digital connectivity paying
for a data plan charging it um having it
lost stolen broken all the time so it
makes it a lot harder to reach that
segment of the demographic all right so
you start a buddy program and then the
buddies are like yo I got to send this
person some money so then
you I don't think they some I mean if
you're we can have you as a buddy and
then we could totally do that but uh it
would take me about 10 seconds to be
like yo I got to send this person some
money you know yeah well we we we've had
we've had uh you know we had folks say
that you know they love the person they
trust and they need money so that was
the starting point um but we've actually
had folks who have declined initially a
basic income because they say I feel
like I get so much value already for my
friend isn't there someone who needs it
more than me um and these are folks
experiencing homelessness so it's not
you know to create this like polanish
like it's just relationships but I do
think the the friendships are like you
know pretty valuable too so oh I mean
friendships can keep you alive it's true
um yeah you know I I would say
friendships plus 200 bucks is like a
yeah or we're doing seven 750 a month
for a year right yeah the the initial
pilot we did was uh 500 a month for six
months and 14 people got you know that
money $3,000 paid out over six months
and then within six months two-thirds of
the folks who were unhoused at the
beginning were able to secure housing
and and basically use the money better
than we could have used it for them and
and so that was like the you know small
but like wow there's something here
let's build on
this this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and your
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com yangang today
that's
expressvpn.com yangang and you can get
an extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
gang
so one of the things you must have have
directly experienced and it does come up
in your book uh is that in places like
New York and San Francisco we're
spending tens of thousands of dollars a
year per homeless person uh and thus was
homelessness solved no no it's not it's
not true like you still go out you're
like what the heck's going on and so
that there's a ton of money being spent
that does not seem to be doing the trick
and large part because to your point
it's not going to the human involved or
the family involved it's going to
something else it's going to the org
it's going through an agency and it
doesn't get to where you'd like it to go
yeah I think one of the things in my
book that uh I wanted to make sure was
centered was just the level of
paternalism in a lot of our service
systems uh where we assume we know
what's better for the person and their
family uh rather than trusting them as
as we'd probably want to be trusted and
invested in um and and you know that
basic income is a form of that but also
meeting a person where they're at you
know if you have 100 people experiencing
homelessness you have a hundred stories
and contexts and situations and you know
a mother with a single child escaping a
domestic violence situation is very
different than someone who has severe
mental health issues substance abuse
issues is very different than someone
who you know had a a health issue that
caused them to not be able to work
anymore and now needing some kind of
disability or some time to rehab so I I
don't believe there's a you know I think
there's a role of course for the
services we have and and if the programs
that we have weren't in place we'd have
a lot more people experiencing
homelessness but to call it efficient or
effective I think would be you know uh
inaccurate and so you know we're we're
trying to meet people where they're at
but not leave them there in the in the
work we do at Miracle messages well it
sounds like you're being very uh
euphemistic about some of these programs
cuz I'm clearly you know um more down on
them I mean you probably interact with
them all the live long day so it's not
for you to be like oh these things are
terrible but I'll I'll say like i' I've
looked at the numbers and like what the
hell's going on like we we spend so much
money uh in ways that are ineffective
and then you go to the or and and the
tough thing too is like I've met with
the orgs uh I've hung out with the orgs
and the orgs consist generally of good
people trying to do positive work uh you
know which is one reason why I sense
that you might be like look I'm not
going to talk smack about um various
folks but but the problem is that I me
there are a lot of problems but uh you
know it's like if you're the good or
trying to do good work and then you run
into like a difficult thorny situation
individual um then there are certain
limits to what you can and can't do I
mean you pretty much need to access the
folks who are most helpable I suppose um
in many ways uh that there are
organizations like Fountain house that
that that do kind of uh hybrid where are
you familiar with that organ ation here
in New York no no I'm not yeah know it's
kind of it's like a house where where
you show up it's like kind of shelter
plus Community plus it's got like a
bunch of services um so so there you
know mental illness is a a pretty big
theme um and and so they they they do a
bunch of things and they're nonprofit
that you know do does do great work but
still I mean when you walk around a
place like New York or San Francisco I
mean you can't miss the evident
homelessness um and then yeah and I I I
tried in the book to really strike a
balance between recognizing identify
what I call like the homelessness
industrial complex you know yeah that's
one that's what I was describing man the
homelessness industrial complex totally
I mean success is measured not by uh
outcomes but by units of service
provided and that outputs versus outcome
is a fun you know it's it leads to the
situation we're in where you have siloed
service providers one siiz fits it's all
but I think what sometimes gets missed
as a Nuance in the conversation that's
important is like homeless Services
don't cause homelessness right it we
have to look at the housing situation
we're in the income inequality Criminal
Justice System foster care system where
one out of every three kids who age out
of the foster care system by the time
they're 26 years old will experience
homelessness so that's where I think you
know we have a lot more people
experiencing homelessness there's a lot
more efficiencies that needed and I'm
not a apologist for the homeless service
system I mean we literally have built an
entire organization on the periphery we
don't work that closely other than like
hey come visit we're happy to work with
you um but I do think there's like a
broader understanding of homelessness
that sometimes gets missed about what
causes homelessness so how much of your
work is in San Francisco uh versus other
environments yeah most of our so our
team is totally a virtual remote around
the country so uh we have four or five
kind of key regions so Bay Area so we do
San Francisco and Oakland with our
current uh randomized control trial of
the basic income in the Pham budy
program and then we have Los Angeles
County uh South Florida uh we have a
team member there that works with a lot
of great organizations on the ground and
then we are starting to have more uh
student chapters uh like UT Austin we
have a bunch of uh students that will go
on their free time to sunrise navigation
Center um Community First Village in
Austin and offer our services either the
Pham buddy program or the reunion
Services um and then we do get inquiries
around the country around our hotline
but those four or five regions are kind
of the main
ones imagine running for president and
wanting to share what you experienced in
a way that's entertaining edifying and
maybe even a little bit scary that's the
last election out in bookstores now a
novel about an independent presidential
candidate a journalist with a massive
story and what the heck could be our
nextlast election check it out at
andrewyang.com
[Music]
well
congratulations uh you built the an an
awesome org and the stories recur
throughout the book uh how did the book
come about and know and what are your
hopes for the book aside from it become
because I'm an author so you know aside
from becoming a bestseller and change
the world like uh you know like every
author aspires to
but I mean it's a very um timely and
important work I enjoyed a lot I learned
a lot from it even though I consider
myself fairly with it on a lot of these
issues um and but it's clear you wrote
the book with a purpose in mind yeah
thanks Andrew I appreciate that that and
you know I I think it was a couple
things uh first and foremost just like
the stories that I tried to lead each
chapter with and and have kind of
interpers interwoven throughout to to
illuminate a theme those stories have
just totally transformed my
understanding of this issue and you know
I've posted on social media we've had
media coverage in the past of our work
but I felt like the context in the
broader narrative was missing you know
two minute sound fight or you know post
one off so I think being able to honor
these stories you know of Elizabeth and
you know being in her 50s and having
colon cancer losing her job as a teacher
going through chemotherapy and ending up
at a you know shelter like that is
forever shaped and shifted my
understanding of homelessness so one was
honoring the stories and weaving them
together with the broader themes I think
the second reason was um you know my
background uh prior to doing miracle
messages and my work as a social
entrepreneur um you know I I did I
graduate work in sociology and my
research was on how disasters and shared
traumas can act as a catalyst to like
bring people together or tear people
apart you know you go through a flood an
earthquake a fire there is this
emergence of what you know uh is
considered in in sociological words like
terms is like the emergence of the
Therapeutic Community you know and it
it's shortlived it's not lasting but
anyways um I felt more and more as I did
work around homelessness that it was
this highly
individualized disaster this non-shared
trauma and yet everyone when we see it
we think of it as this like you know
private thing and you almost assume well
what did you do wrong you know this this
Notions of individualism of like who's
to blame but but the more I thought
about was like this is just really like
everyone just went through an earthquake
or a flood or a fire but no one knows
that the other person just went through
the same thing um and I thought that
perhaps if we brought this broader
narrative you know I I do mention about
the disaster element but I I really
focus on other systems that perhaps like
will activate our Humanity a little bit
more than we are right now yeah and and
and and that is uh a big theme in the
last part of the book it is about trying
to re Kindle Humanity which I
appreciated uh a great deal uh so what
can people do to help and I know that's
somewhat fraught given that you run this
awesome organization uh miracl
messages.org check it out you too can
help connect someone uh with their
family uh and become a buddy donate um
but aside I mean not aside from because
what what's interesting is and I I do
appreciate the fact that you open the
book by being like look guys like you
know I am just like you where but then
you've had this journey you on um that
has now resulted in uh hundreds probably
um thousands of people being helped in
various ways uh what would you ask
someone to do in their own lives or it
could be just you know go to miracl
messages.org uh send money become a
mentor uh buy the book spread the
message yeah I mean that's definitely
one of things uh we we try to make our
services as accessible as possible so
you know right now we have a weit list
of individuals who are unhoused who've
raised their hand and said I need a
friend to talk to and we don't have
enough volunteers to match them with so
wow inviting folks to commit you know 20
minutes a week 30 minutes a week we
assign a phone number through dial pad
uh you know can use Google Voice you
don't have to use your device number
there's weekly trainings there's support
calls so definitely if you know folks
want to be a phone buddy and and being
able to be in relationship that's great
and and they can sign up at miracl
messages.org awesome but I think yeah I
I think more broadly like this idea that
um we care about this issue everyone
says you know this is an issue that
matters to them it's one of the tops
sited issues in our cities but I think
very few of us can say we know someone
who's currently experiencing
homelessness in any capacity and that to
me is part of the problem you know it's
this AB raction we don't know their
names we don't know their stories at an
intimate level so honestly just being
able to say by the end of the year hey
what does it take to maybe it's the
person you walk by every day uh who you
know you've said hi to but you never
taken a moment to cheer their story
going to a local shelter soup kitchen
doing a phone buddy program uh because I
do think transformation can happen
through relationships in fact that's one
of the only ways I've seen know hearts
and Minds change on this issue um and I
think you know the last one is it's a
the the terms and the language that we
use you know matter a great deal um we
would never look at each other as like
housed people as a primary identity and
yet we've defined an entire group of
people by their lack of one physical
need which is the homeless uh so I I try
to you know just be a little bit more uh
you know circumspect in the language I
use people experiencing homelessness
unhoused neighbors um and it's not to be
like overly you know bureaucratic
pedantic like procedural it's more just
making sure we really see someone as
someone's son or daughter brother or
sister rather than as like a homeless
person you know and that's not their
primary identity so congratulations
Kevin this a very uplifting uh beautiful
message the book is great your
organization is great I'm going to make
a donation to Miracle messages miracl
messages.org um to to just show that
you're doing awesome incredible work
that if people were to heed your message
of humanity we'd be in much better shape
not just on homelessness but on a lot of
other issues well thanks Andrew and and
thanks for always uh leading with
humanity and all the work you do I mean
it's it's really a pleasure to get to
know you as a friend and to you know be
in conversation with you right back at
you Kevin uh you're a better person than
just about all all all of us really like
who the heck could say they've reunited
um you know 800 plus people with their
their loved ones uh the founder of
Miracle messages it's miracl
messages.org author of when we walk by
forgotten Humanity broken systems and
the role we can each play in ending
homelessness in America check him out is
there a way that people can follow you
personally Kevin yeah I'm on I guess all
the social media most of it's just Kevin
F Adler I so Instagram Twitter Kevin F
Adler um so you can find me there
excellent maybe we can get to your
million person goal man screw it let's
get these million people I mean heck we
you know look at it's like any moment
let's go for the million let's go for
the million yeah let's let's make it
[Music]
happen